We're speaking today with Eric
Brynjolfsson, a professor here
at MIT Sloan School
of Management,
the director of the MIT
Initiative on the Digital
Economy, and co-author
of a bestselling book,
The Second Machine
Age, a book that really
has gotten the
conversation going
about how important
today's digital economy is,
how the technologies
that are coming along
are going to have an enormous
effect on the future of work.
So Eric, thank you
for joining us.
It's a real pleasure.
Good.
Let's get started.
Why don't you tell
us why you think
the current technological
wave of innovation
is as important as the
first Industrial Revolution,
with the steam engine and all
the things that went with it.
Well, you know,
technologies make
a huge difference in the
living standards of people.
For centuries, living standards
were essentially stagnant
until James Watt and others
developed a better steam
engine, and that ignited
the Industrial Revolution.
And ever since then,
living standards
have been growing about 2% per
year, which adds up to a lot.
What those
technologies really did
was they augmented
and automated a lot
of muscle power from humans
and animals to machines.
What we're seeing
now is that machines
are beginning to be able
to do the same thing
for our brains and our minds.
We have computers and
software and big data
that are learning how to
help us make decisions,
how to extend our
mental capacity.
And that's at least as profound
a difference as what the steam
engine and, later, the
internal combustion
engine and other technologies
did for our muscles.
Well, it's very clear that
technological changes like this
are very good for the economy,
but they also affect work.
Tell us a little bit about
how technologies affect
work in what ways-- in positive
ways, in negative ways--
and then we can
go on from there.
Sure.
Well, the big headline
is the first one
you mentioned, that the
pie is getting bigger.
And so we have to
keep sight of that,
that basically these are
technologies that create
more abundance, more wealth.
And there's more wealth now than
there ever has been in history,
and global poverty
is going down.
So that's the good news.
But the reality is that
there's no economic law that
says that everyone's going
to benefit evenly from this.
It's possible for some
people to be made worse off.
In fact, there's
no economic reason
that you couldn't have
a majority of people
be made worse off, even as other
people get much, much better.
Through most of
history, there was
a rising tide that lifted
most boats, almost all boats.
But in the past 20
years or so, there's
been what we call a
decoupling, where productivity
has continued to grow, GDP per
capita has continued to grow,
but the median income, the 50th
percentile and those below it,
have seen their incomes
stagnate or even fall.
And that reflects the fact
that these technologies
don't affect everybody evenly.
So let's play this out.
How do you see these
technologies affecting work
in the future?
Well, the technologies
continue to advance,
and they continue to affect
different kinds of jobs.
But what really matters is
how we go about using them.
What we've seen so far is
that many of the technologies
have been used to
automate a lot of routine
information-processing work,
things like bank tellers,
bookkeepers, a lot
of middle managers.
In fact, about 60% of
Americans primarily
do information-processing
work, so that's a big category.
And machines are very
good at automating
a lot of these,
especially the more
repetitive, routine
information-processing tasks.
It turns out that the people
who do those jobs are typically
in the middle of the
income distribution,
and what they've seen is
that as machines get better
at those tasks, there's
less demand for humans
to do the identical tasks.
Or if they do still
have jobs, they
have to compete with
machines that are doing them
more and more cheaply.
And that his pushed down wages.
It's led to fewer
job opportunities
in those categories.
At the same time, there's been
growth in job opportunities
at the other ends of
the spectrum, what
David Autor and other people
call job polarization.
At the high end, you
get creative people
or entrepreneurs are
making, in some cases,
more money than ever before.
It's probably the
best time in history.
If you have some kind
of special talent
that could be
replicated digitally,
you might end up
being a billionaire.
On the other hand, the
other end of the spectrum
has also seen some
growth, and those
are jobs that require a lot
of dexterity or physical tasks
or interpersonal skills,
things that machines
aren't very good at.
The thing is, often those
jobs don't pay very well.
And just to be specific,
those are the kinds
of jobs like a
waiter or a gardener
or a janitor, those
kinds of tasks.
So what is your advice,
then, to workers
facing this world of
changing technology?
What should they
do in order to be
able to prosper in this world?
Well, what you'd
like to try to do
is strengthen those
areas where humans have
an advantage over machines.
You don't really want to be
competing against machines.
Ideally, you'd like to
do things were machines
can leverage your talents.
Data scientists
are more in demand
than ever before,
because machines
have created an
abundance of data,
but they can't analyze it.
They can't even ask the
right questions themselves.
You need humans to do that.
And so if you have
those kinds of skills,
you're more valuable than ever.
And Silicon Valley,
and now companies
throughout the
country and the world,
are greatly demanding
those kinds of workers.
And so there's a set of
categories around that.
I mentioned earlier, if you have
some kind of special talents
or creativity, machines
aren't very creative.
People who can sing well or
who can invent new businesses,
as entrepreneurs, many kinds
of scientists, artists,
if you're a great
writer or write books,
those are things
that are probably
more valuable now than before.
Another big category that's
gotten to be more valuable is--
I touched on it earlier-- is
some of these interpersonal
skills--
nurturing and caring.
I don't think it would
have been very motivating
if, at the half time of the
football games last weekend,
the coach had been
a robot coach.
You need a human to do that.
And that means that
leadership, team work,
those kinds of things.
We still connect with
other people a lot better,
and we will for some time.
And I think all those skills,
from the creative ones
to the interpersonal, the
teamwork, the nurturing skills,
they can all be developed.
And I would encourage
people to work harder
at developing those
kinds of skills.
Become a better salesperson,
negotiator, nurturing,
caring for people, nursing.
Those are all things
that I expect to grow,
even as machines
take care of more
and more of the routine,
repetitive kinds of tasks.
So that's great advice
to the workforce.
Let's talk a bit about
the people who are
designing these technologies.
How can we encourage
more technological design
that complements work, that
utilizes these skills, that
thinks about ways
to enhance them
or to work with them
to drive productivity
and economic performance?
Well, I'm glad you
asked that question,
because most people
don't even get
as far as asking that question.
I think there's a
widespread assumption
out there that
technology just happens,
and there's nothing you can
do to shape the path of it.
The reality is that you
can encourage people
to have technologies that create
more inclusive innovation, that
helps people more
broadly, or that
mostly focuses on substituting
for people, for that matter.
And we, as a society
and as individuals,
can shape the
direction of technology
to quite a significant extent.
One of the things we can do is
change around our tax policy
and our government policies.
One of the oldest
rules of economics
is if you want less of
something, you tax it.
If you want more of
something, you subsidize it.
Right now, ironically,
we are taxing work.
If two entrepreneurs come up
with a billion-dollar idea,
and one of them involves
employing lots of people
and one of them doesn't,
our current tax system
will put more taxes on the
one that employs more people,
and that's probably
not we want to do.
Conversely, we don't tax
pollution, carbon, congestion,
things that we'd
like to see less of.
So we could rejigger
the tax system
to tax the things that
we don't want more,
and then we'll have less of
them, and lower the taxes,
or even subsidize, work.
And I think that would
guide entrepreneurs
to be more creative
about inventing
things that have less pollution
and more widespread labor.
The Earned Income Tax Credit is
a good example, but too small.
Could be expanded at that.
Another kind of
thing we could do
is just recognize reward
and motivate people.
One of the things that I've
learned over the past few years
is how much people
can be motivated
by having a prize and a
goal in front of them.
I've been watching
the DARPA Robotics
Challenge, the DARPA
Grand Challenge that
led to the driverless car.
And I see my colleagues
in engineering,
grad students, professors
working nights and weekends
to solve this challenge that
has been put in front of them.
And many times,
they do come around
to making huge strides in that.
Why don't we try to
reward and motivate
business leaders and
economists to reinvent
the businesses and
economy the same way
that technologists have been
reinventing the technology?
And in fact, here at MIT,
we're launching something
called the Inclusive
Innovation Competition, which
is designed specifically
to recognize those business
models that use technology
to create broad,
shared prosperity.
We call it shared prosperity
for the many, not just the few.
It's just getting
launched, but we
think this is going to be a good
way to recognize and highlight
people who have done that.
I think that's a
great idea, and I
hope that it creates
a lot of attention,
and that we get lots of
people really thinking along
these ways, because I think
it's the genius of people--
using technologies to address
important problems that
will help make progress.
Yeah, and we all have choices.
We can shape the future
in that direction.
And why don't we
encourage people
who are doing it in a way
that does create this shared
prosperity?
So let me ask this final
question, because it's
obviously on everybody's mind.
And that is, from time
to time in history,
as you know better than
I, people have worried
that technology is
going to replace work,
it's going to be
the end of work,
we're not going to
have enough jobs.
And that's an issue on
people's mind today.
How do you think about
that problem, given
all of the innovation
that's going on
and that could
come down the road?
Well, down the road,
I could certainly
imagine technology creating
kind of a Star Trek economy.
And I don't think that's
necessarily a bad thing
if technology's able to take
care of all of our basic needs
for us.
But the more
immediate issue is not
that technology is
going to eliminate
all the jobs, but the types
of jobs that are affected.
The reality is that technology's
always been destroying jobs.
It's always been creating jobs.
But most importantly, it's
been changing the mix.
And what we're seeing recently,
as I touched on earlier,
is that mix is changing in
a way that a lot of people
are being made worse
off, and other people are
being made much better off.
And we want to try to shape the
direction of the technology.
We want to also give people
the skills and education
so they can adapt to
the new kinds of jobs
that are available.
And if we do that,
I think we're going
to be able to have that kind
of world of shared prosperity.
The technology will march
on, and we shouldn't
try to stop the technology.
That's how we get
that bigger pie,
that growth that I mentioned.
But we can direct it.
In the earlier
industrial revolutions,
when the steam engine and
other technologies came along,
we adapted our institutions.
We invented mass
public education,
first at the primary
level, and then later
at the secondary level.
We invented social security and
a whole bunch of other policies
that helped smooth
that transition
to a new kind of work
force and cushioned
the people who otherwise
would have been left behind.
We're going to have to
reinvent education again.
And this time,
we're going to have
to do our best to shape
the technology that
is aligned with our values.
Ultimately, it's not what
the technology does to us.
Technology is a tool.
It's always been a tool, whether
it's a hammer or an enterprise
resource planning system.
We have more powerful tools
now than we ever had before,
and that means we have more
power to shape the future
than we ever did before.
But it starts with understanding
that we have that power,
and aligning our
actions with our values.
Well, Eric, I think that's
a really important message,
and one that I'm delighted that
we can deliver in this class
and in other settings
where people can really
make a difference.
So thanks for joining us today.
It's a tremendous pleasure.
Thanks a lot, Tom.